Sarah Jessica Parker Cynthia Nixon and
Kristen Davis have broken their silence
over the Chris Noth sexual assault
allegations sharing this message to
their Instagram story Monday night quote
we are deeply saddened to hear the
allegations against Chris Noth we
support the women who have come forward
and shared their painful experiences we
know it must be a very difficult thing
to do and we commend them for it it's
the first time nof's co-stars have
spoken out about the allegations since
the news dropped last week the actor has
denied all allegations
come on do you I don't think so their
message comes shortly after Nova was
fired from the TV series The Equalizer
in a joint statement on Monday CBS and
Universal television said Noth will no
longer film episodes for the TV show
effective immediately
A3 artist agency also dropped notes as a
client
last Thursday two women came forward to
The Hollywood Reporter with sexual
assault allegations the next day The
Daily Beast published a third account
from a woman alleging nope sexually
assaulted her
I remember when your hair was black oh
oh really uncalled for the initial two
women stated they came forward now after
being triggered by no surprisal of Mr
Big in and just like that in a statement
CET note called both accusations quote
categorically false adding the
encounters were consensual